from portion sizes to exclusives we
wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's and the US UK Japan
and India this is food Wars
in the U.S are McDonald's sodas come in
three sizes
small
medium this is what a medium drink looks
like Japan's large
regular medium and large
[Music]
our chicken McNuggets come in 4 6 10 20
or 40 piece so with our McNuggets in the
UK the default adult sizes on the menu
a box of six six pieces a box of nine
pieces or 20 pieces they gave it to us
in two boxes of ten each in Japan our
chickenback nuggets come in 5 and 15
pesos
[Music]
in the US you get your fries in four
sizes kids if you get a Happy Meal some
Smiles in the paperback medium Bean
fries and large
fries in India come in three sizes
regular medium and large the medium and
large come in these really cool new
packaging where you can just open it up
like that and it's nice and easy to
share it's a little plate good job
McDonald's very Innovative so we can
find an exact weight measurement for the
fries online so what we're gonna do is
wear them ourselves
wow
yeah wow that worked perfectly the thing
I just did there great job Joe
three exclusive Burgers here in the US
are variation on the quarter pounder
with cheese yes we've all seen Pulp
Fiction we know about the whole quarter
Ponder thing does not exist outside of
the US I don't think so the classic
quarter pounder with cheese look at this
guy I mean this is maybe my go-to one
for a decade the quarter pounder with
cheese deluxe I don't know
I feel like this is pretty close to a
Whopper I'm not a big Whopper Guy The
Double Quarter Pounder with cheese look
at the size of this thing yes sir so
here we've got the veggie deluxe burger
which is a veggie burger that's served
with some mayo and some lettuce here
we've got a chicken Legend
which is a chicken burger again served
with my own lettuce with a range of
wraps that you can get in the UK we have
a wrap of the day here we've got the
fighter crisp which is some chicken
along with some veg and some spicy
fajita sauce Japan's exclusive Burgers
Teriyaki mock Burger which is my most
favorite one my body is made of material
fiber
bacon lettuce burger right here it looks
sad
egg cheeseburger but we also call it
eguchi eggs is an abbreviation for egg
cheese burger Japanese people love
abbreviation next one spicy beef burger
oh look at this oh it looks so spicy
especially mayo or something like that
the sheer we've got Samurai muck
Samurai and this blue one is called
rasted soy sauce double thick beef we've
got roasted soy sauce bacon tomato thick
beef and this one right here is called
teriyaki chicken filet wow so much sauce
so next one we've got ebi filio Ebby
mainstream so it's a shrimp paleo oh
yeah it's got Aurora sauce Aura sauce is
like a ketchup and mayonnaise
so it's got a lot of shrimp in there
hmm
it's okay so good here in India we can't
really recreate the iconic McDonald's
Big Mac because it's made from a beef
patty and to keep to the religious
Sentiments of Hindus and even Muslims we
don't serve beef or pork in a lot of
fast food restaurants we have something
called the chicken Maharaja Mac as you
can see it's got three buns two patties
a lot of cheese and mayonnaise
oh my God
that is truly a Maharaja Mac now let's
see it's the veg Maharaja Mac like look
at this this is outrageous there's no
way to eat this without being messy
oh my God that's really good all right
next up is the iconic mikalu Tiki Burger
you take mashed potato and you fry it in
breadcrumbs and you get this really
delicious cutlet
it's just so classic they kneel this
burger next up they have a Mac egg
burger Mac egg make egg make egg I don't
know why I did that let's see what that
looks like
sorry I did not expect pesto next up is
a chicken kebab Burger this is not what
we're used to seeing when we think of
Kebabs the mech veggie which is the
vegetarian counterpart to our McChicken
if I had to eat this versus the Chicken
one I would not be upset at all really
good we have two American Burgers the
American cheese Supreme wedge
and the American cheese Supreme chicken
all right so this is what the McDonald's
website says is in this burger whole
wheat bun sauce from Maharashtra Tangy
jalapenos from Karnataka shredded onions
grown in local Indian farms and cheese
from amravati also in India quite quite
close to home this burger currently this
would probably be my favorite order a
mixed spicy chicken and as the
vegetarian option which is a mixed spicy
paneer which is just leaking lettuce for
those of you who don't know what paneer
is it's basically cottage cheese we love
our paneer we put in curries we eat a
plain we put it in kebabs it is so
delicious fair warning while this may
have a light kick of spice for us it
might be a hard kick for you so take
everything with a pinch of chili powder
every fast food chain in America right
now is having what we're calling the
fried chicken sandwich Wars Popeyes uh
Burger King of course McDonald's all of
them are at this arms race to have the
best chicken sandwich I think because
Chick-fil-A has edged everyone out these
are the three that are currently
available I don't know for how long
there's a crispy chicken sandwich I
think it's a brioche bun uh pickles
and no sauce which I think is strange
like the whole flavor is just just the
chicken spicy
chicken sandwich same deal but of course
spicy sauce and the spicy chicken Deluxe
which has more vegetables on it you know
to be healthier
actually we were supposed to have buy
Burger options but fortunately you can
only get them from 5 30 PM but let me
explain what by Burger is buy simply
means double in Japanese so if you order
a normal Big Mac it has two big parties
right but if you order buy big mug it
has four beef patties but not not only
Big Mac but all burgers and adapts
applied Burger options that would not
stand in this country at all people
would lose their minds four patties I
want a Big Mac what we lack in beef
burgers we make up for in Gourmet
Burgers that's right here in McDonald's
India we have our own collection of Chef
special Gourmet Burgers delicious and I
think this is a rolling menu I think
they introduce new things from time to
time the Buns themselves look a lot more
Gourmet you know this nice riff down the
middle kind of looks like a butt uh but
that's okay we're not going to
concentrate on that
first we have triple cheese American veg
burger and triple cheese American
chicken burger cheese lava American veg
burger and cheese lava American chicken
burger again with American and again
with the with a Strange Relation of food
to volcanoes and lava
this burger is very spicy this qualifies
as a volcano product for sure
congratulations McDonald's the lava in
the title of this Burger Works the MC
spicy chicken premium though has an egg
Patty inside of it
um
that's pretty good
I just feel so existential right now
imagine sitting here at this table and
just tasting every single burger or
McDonald's menu
amazing
but also
we also have some exclusive wrap options
we have big spicy paneer and big spicy
chicken I think this is the same mix
spicy chicken patty and it's wrapped
around a tortilla Which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati than most of
the fast food restaurants it doesn't
feel as synthetic okay so when it comes
to SAR menus we've got Shaka Shaka
chicken
and we have two flat oh two flavors can
you hear that
thunder thunder because it's raining
season in Japan
the sunny season here in Southern
California
and here is red pepper and this one is
cheddar cheese
found here stop
so all you have to do is just put the
powder into the back
and
check it
and the powder should be covered in the
whole Shaka chicken
big one
like this
[Music]
we've got side salad and it comes with
this roasted sesame dressing let's go
that was cool now put it all in the
garbage we've got
edamame and corn
yogurt
and there is cow
cow
here we've got some Veggie Dippers these
were actually introduced as part of
veganery in 2020 in the UK but they're
stuck on the menu so these are vegan
Society approved and they're sort of
like a fried bean Patty sort of thing
and then finally we've got some
mozzarella Dippers which are just kind
of mozzarella sticks really
here in India we have these add-ons
number one the veg Pizza mcpuff it's
basically a pizza hot pocket Masala
veggies these are potato wedges with
classic Indian Masala flavor to them
masalas are basically what we use to
spice and flavor dishes and they consist
primarily of ground up spices like
cardamom cloves red chillies kashmiri
chilies you go to Every Indian home the
mums the grandmoms will have their own
random you know Masala mix that's
guarded and treasured in their family
forever next up we have cheesy Masala
veggies they're also serving a classic
cup of boiled corn which is so unique
and they give you a side of amul butter
amul butter is part of our culture
makhan makhan this is probably going to
be the most delicious bite of the day
I love corn next up chicken strips they
come in packs of two
three or five cheesy nugget veg bites
this is just a vegetarian version of the
chicken nuggets next we have the double
cheese McMuffin and lastly we have
Mexican cheesy fries on the McDonald's
India website one British customer said
that these Mexican cheesy fries are the
real deal I have no idea how a British
person can say that Mexican cheesy fries
is a real deal but anytime a British
person says that another culture is food
is the real deal it puts a little fear
in our small Indian Hearts so let's go
with soft drinks right here Fanta grape
and here is Phantom melon and this one
is Japanese vegetable juice and there is
I guess more than 20 or 30 vegetables in
it and it's good for health for sure
itadakimasu
we've got coo white grape so
kombucha is like a Japanese Blended tea
town and Japanese people drink this on a
daily basis so next one we've got are
all gray iced tea let me show you
wait
there is something
there's a mosquito
I have to make a complaint Japanese
McDonald's
next one we've got
so this is not actually Japanese tea
it's a Chinese tea that's good for
health as well for health we do have
a mango pineapple smoothie
and a banana strawberry smoothie
smoothies are fruit in it right
oh yeah
I can just feel the nutrients coursing
through my veins
we have something called B Naturals
mixed fruit juice we have something that
they call Raw mango fruit splash
oh it's a bit too sweet Berry lemonade
Splash all of these come in these very
unique reusable bottles apparently next
up strawberry Chiller green apple
Chiller and lemon chiller
it's just flavored water that's exactly
what it is it's flavored water and I
kind of like it this is a mixed berry
smoothie
it's still quite sweet but quite good
next up American mud pie shake
um
that's pretty um exclusive hot drinks
first off we have strawberry green tea
next up uh English breakfast tea and
Moroccan tea a flat white coffee India a
land where we run on chai and McDonald's
does not have a chai option waffle Kong
right here so we got plain so play means
it's like Rich milk taste and next one
is strawberry strawberry personally I
like this the next one is chocolate and
almond right there
hmm it's not melting good job buddy so
here we've got Mac flows so macros means
there is soda and on top of that there's
ice cream that's it that's it and this
is macroots melon
sweet
great coffee mug floats
um
and the last one we've got Coke Muk
floats
hmm oh uh we have two exclusive slushies
one is a pink lemonade strawberry
watermelon yeah dude
looks real good hot caramel sundae and
the classic fudge sundae we have a black
forest McFlurry a vanilla chocolate
muffin and a chocolate chip muffin it's
kind of like a McFlurry soup right now
this would be really good when it was
actually a McFlurry exclusive sauces
it's sauce talk time sauce talk we have
sweet and sour sauce they gave me hot
mustard
this would be honey mustard of course
Ranch
uh ooh spicy buffalo now these might be
promotions because of that uh singing
group BTS but we have right now a Cajun
sauce and a sweet chili sauce
the sauce is fantastic this is the sauce
this has to stay in the menu so these
two are new ones
this one right here is soy sauce best
sauce
man this is fantastic good job
so this one right here is called
Louisiana hostos oh it does look like
very spicy one
[Music]
this is not spicy at all then we've got
a couple of sauces that are kind of
unique to the UK as well we've got a
sweet Curry dipping sauce
and then we've also got a salsa dip as
well which I didn't know existed until
today we have one exclusive
exclude spice mix as well as One
exclusive sauce here in India we have
chili sauce which is pretty
straightforward it's chili sauce but let
me tell you about piri piri spice mix
first you get this shake bag then you
grab your fries and then you just pour
that in there
oh
boom oh boy can we cut to a before of
the fries you saw how they were now look
at these you can see the little flecks
of spice just adorning each fry if there
isn't
like crack
okay breakfast time this is a breakfast
burrito oh
neon yellow egg Mexican style salsa not
to be confused with what Canadian salsa
let's go on to these breakfast
sandwiches here I don't know how to
describe a biscuit other than it's dry
baked maybe they're made with cornmeal
according to the internet this is not a
scone so there you go sausage egg and
cheese our egg is like this fluffy
folded scramble egg egg this is how we
do in the U.S bacon egg and cheese is
there a better breakfast combination in
the world I don't think there is then
they just have the sausage no egg no
cheese just sausage and biscuit we have
regular size hotcakes and we have a hot
cake and sausage combo of course
comes with syrup and
butter
very natural pose
very natural feeling right now always up
for a pork yes
breakfast is served
oatmeal on the side to be mixed in
cranberries and raisins and
diced oh
diced apples
and here we've got Mega muffin pork
patties that's huge one
mini pancakes
oh cute it comes with apple cream sauce
[Music]
this is perfect for breakfast I will get
it bacon egg MC sandwich so it's got
bacon and round egg and cheddar cheese
that's it and you might be surprised
we've got fellow fish tada uh Sophia
Fish is on the breakfast menu I guess
Japanese people tend to eat fish for
breakfast we have a veg McMuffin and a
sausage McMuffin
the sausage here in India is not made
out of pork like it is in the U.S
instead it's made out of simple chicken
[Music]
so while McDonald's fries might look and
taste pretty similar in the UK and the
US in the UK we only have three
ingredients which is oil salt and
potatoes
the McDonald's french fries in America
have way more ingredients these fries
are made from potatoes obviously a
vegetable oil which is canola oil corn
oil soybean oil
hydrogenic hydrogenitated
genotated
thank you hydrogenated soybean oil
natural beef flavor dextrose sodium acid
phosphatate phosphate fast but
pyrophosphate pyrophosphate sodium acid
pyrophosphate which is used to maintain
the color uh are they that much of a
different color than the ones in the UK
is it worth it could you get a
side-by-side comparison are they that
much more bright yellow we need to put
sodium acid pyrophosphate or whatever
it's called in it
salt and I should mention that a natural
beef flavor contains hydrolyzed wheat
and hydrolyzed milk as a starting
ingredient and of course I have no idea
what that means McDonald's India does
not share a full list of their
ingredients but there are some things we
do know about their food like did you
know that McDonald's India actually
changed Indian farming practices just so
they could grow the kind of potato that
they wanted when they first launched in
India in 1996 McDonald's promised the
government that they would use products
grown and sourced right here in India
but people who had eaten McDonald's
abroad realized that the fries didn't
taste quite the same the reason for this
is that Indian potatoes were too small
around had way too much moisture and
sugar content and so the fries made out
of them were not long enough they didn't
get crispy enough and they didn't have
that distinctive McDonald's oomph to
them so McDonald's partnered with making
foods and they spent nine years trying
to perfect their potato they imported
saplings which had the perfect shape and
starch content that they need it they
also chose Gujarat as their farming
location for its climate and they
switched from a flood irrigation to a
sprinkler system to reduce moisture
content and save water the result bigger
and more starchy potatoes that can be
used to make the McDonald's fries that
you know and love so McDonald's Japan
doesn't disclose their ingredients in
the Big Mac however they do tell us
where the ingredients come from if you
order a Big Mac in Japan you'll eat beef
from Australia or New Zealand buns made
from wheat imported from the USA Canada
and Australia and pickles made from
cucumbers grown in Turkey Sri Lanka or
India onions grown in the USA or India
sliced cheddar cheese made in New
Zealand Australia the USA or Japan and
Lettuce grown in Japan Taiwan the USA or
Malaysia the only ingredients that come
from Japan are the cheese and the
lettuce and even then McDonald's still
import some lettuce and cheese from
other countries so this is a very
International Burger
thank you world
[Music]